parents I know you find yourselves at
home with who knows what kind of
textbooks and what kind of advice from
your teacher and I thought I'd give you
four basic tips that you can use to be
successful with homeschooling number one
this is a very important time for
parents and teachers to work together
you have always been partnered with the
teacher of your child but good
communication between parent and teacher
has never been more important so feel
free to email teachers make sure that
you understand what they're saying and
give them feedback about what you're
seeing at home remember teachers have
never been through this either and they
need information from you in order to do
it successfully number two this is a
great opportunity to remember that
education is not about jumping through
hoops the schedule of the school day is
usually a pretty rigorous schedule
students are in school from around eight
o'clock to around three o'clock and
they've got all kinds of activities
aren't music PE the kinds of things that
it just doesn't make sense to replicate
when you're at home so parents give
yourselves a little bit of grace
remember that it may not be possible to
do every single activity that your kids
are used to doing during the school day
and that's okay this is an opportunity
for us to think about what we really
want out of our children's education and
to focus on the true essence the really
important things that we want our kids
to learn number three keep things simple
it's very easy I think to spend a lot of
our time right now thinking about the
technicalities thinking about what is
the perfect system that will enable us
to keep things moving and we don't need
to worry about that right now
there are a bunch of things that our
students already know how to do that are
really worth doing so for example
reading great literature this is a time
to pick up that book that you loved when
you were a child or to pick up a book
that you've always wanted to read with
your child and spend some time as a
family spend some time reading that book
to those children number four
encourage organization and structure get
some habits in place now that will serve
you well next week next month maybe even
two or three months down the road we
don't know how long this is going to
last but we know that if we put some
structure behind our
work that it will make things more
smooth down the road above all whether
you're a teacher or a parent now is the
time to think about quality over
quantity don't focus on the amount of
work the number of objectives a child
was going to achieve for this trimester
or quarter instead think about the
quality of the work that the children
are doing and let that be your guide
you